well the session kicking off with all
the traditional pomp and circumstance
we're used to
except with a lot of hand sanitizer
masks
and covet tests everybody entering the
building today had to get
covid tested and a lot of this session
will be held
virtually on zoom and online but if you
watched the feed
you wouldn't have noticed it new
lawmakers were sworn in
leadership positions named everybody
wearing masks
and tested like i mentioned the big
topics for the legislature this year is
how to pay for state services with money
we simply don't have
because of what the pandemic did to our
state so does that mean
any new taxes well here's what the house
speaker
and republican minority leader have to
say about that
whether it's social justice or you know
revenue
i i think that we're going to have to
deal with those and struggle through
some of those
areas where we might not agree but also
be willing to find some common ground
compromises
we have a very antiquated
tax system and a very complicated tax
system
do we need to have an overview of the
nevada tax system
absolutely
so the word of the day is certainly
compromise but we'll see how long that
lasts of course with now 119 days left
of this session
now one person we talked to today is new
assembly woman
annie black now you might remember that
name she is the republican assemblywoman
from clark county who attended former
president trump's stop the steel rally
taking some photos and videos
now as you see she was at that protest
outside the capitol but
she wasn't part of the mob in any way
and she didn't go inside the building
some democrats had called for her to
resign but she told me today she
is being welcomed here with open arms
they respect my first amendment rights
free speech and
i didn't break any laws so that's what
they're telling me that's
so that's all i know
now the legislature started its work
today with two
open seats one in the senate and one in
the assembly both from clark county both
democrats and tomorrow the clark county
commission
will fill those vacancies we're live in
carson city tonight i'm david charns 8
news now